I remember the specific reason reasons
why I wanted to become a doctor this is
going to sound a little foolish maybe
and i said this numerous times before
but it was the TV show Ben Casey when i
was a kid i guess it was i was maybe 10
8 9 10 11 12 in that range i used to
watch Ben Casey and I thought that he
was the absolutely coolest person I ever
saw right and he did things for people
and he he was able to accomplish things
make people better and sometimes not
being people better but it was a very
powerful experience for me as a kid and
they stayed with me now you may recall
at that time back in the early 60s there
was another show a doctor show dr.
Kildare so you had been casing and dr.
Kildare I didn't like dr. Kildare that
much but I like Ben Casey right that's
what really kind of turned me on to it
now I'm going to fast-forward 40 years
later and my assistant longtime
assistant my birthday two years ago got
me the all the Ben Casey episodes on DVD
and I have to tell you I watched the
number them brought back fond memories
but Ben Casey is not the doctor that I
wanted to be that's for sure it's a
whole different model of being a
physician first of all he's a chief
resident in neurosurgery at a County
Hospital but he seems like he's running
the whole hospital right now chief
residents don't run hospitals in
addition he is the most out of touch in
terms of human emotions and what you
have to do to talk to people and
recognize their feelings and emotions
that you can imagine occasionally
there's this flash of light that you see
some empathy and humanity at him but for
the most part he's got kind of a
brooding you know stereotypical surgeon
you know no tolerance for anybody
yelling at the nurses you know it was
really not ultimately right not the
physician I or anybody else should
really be
well I think they come in two areas
first of all over the last 20 or 30
years the innovations in treating
arthritic joints have been astounding I
mean basically but we now can take auth
hritik worn out joints replace them with
artificial joints and provide patients
with ninety-five percent or more
certainty that they will have a
successful result be relatively
pain-free improve their activity improve
their quality of life I mean that's a
very powerful thing to do now keep in
mind the orthopedic surgery is a
specialty that for the most part doesn't
deal with life and death situations we
deal with quality of life situations so
we focus on improving people's quality
of life and whether it be hip
replacement or knee replacement shoulder
replacement or even elbow replacement
these types of procedures take patients
who are terribly disabled right and
allow them to become more mobile walk
play athletics do the things that they
want to do right when they really didn't
think it was possible before before so
it then to me that's a very powerful
thing now now that's on the on the
treatment side you know there's a lot of
research being done on the prevention
side preventing joints from getting to
that point where they need a joint
replacement now that has to do with
manipulating you know the genetic basis
of articular cartilage and the
structures around the joint and I think
that holds great promise it's not here
yet and ultimately you know things like
that may decrease the need for joint
replacements
well I the key element in your
replacement is longevity taking a person
who needs a joint replacement and giving
them a replacement that will last the
rest of their lives now when your
replacement first thought of being done
in the 60s or even the 70s it was
reserved for people in their 60s 70s or
such because there was concerned about
the longevity however over the last 30
years advancements in the design the
materials that are involved that are
used for joint replacement have allowed
the joint replacements to last longer
and longer so it's possible to take now
a 50 year old or a 40 year old replace
their hip or knee and anticipate that
they will have that replacement in place
for the rest of their lives so the rest
of the lives is different to find us 30
40 or 50 years as opposed to maybe 10 15
or 20 years and I think that's where the
advancements are going to come in the
materials that are being used to a
certain extent the design
it's interesting hip and knee
replacement has tended to get the
emphasis in the area of your replacement
because you know hips and knees are
really necessary for your mobility the
ability to walk work do the things that
you have to do each day you get out of
bed and walk to the bathroom or get up
and walk around the kitchen to do all
the things that are considered necessary
your mobility your shoulders and elbows
have generally taken a backseat to a
certain extent primarily because if you
can't do something with one arm well you
can probably compensate for it with the
other arm so it tends to get less
attention in addition there's the
perception that the shoulder elbow is
not a weight-bearing joint like the hip
and the knee and that's true to a
certain extent although there are
significant forces that are generated
across the shoulder in the elbow such
that when they're arthritic they take
they can be very painful
well you know athletic injuries have
really increased in incidents over the
last 20 years in a very rapid rate now
why is that well I think that first and
foremost the reason is that more and
more people are involved in athletics
just bottom line you see athletics
they're being being organized athletics
starting when when children are just in
elementary school right its extensive
throughout you know they're only the
elementary school middle school high
school is a explosion of college
athletics at all different all different
sports and then his recreational sports
more and more people are involved in it
in addition they're also involved in it
to a much greater degree in later years
it's not unheard of to have people in
there it used to be that somebody tore
their anterior cruciate ligament which
is a key stabilizing ligament to the
knee you expected that to be somebody in
their 20s maybe the early 30s and then
you would consider replacing it now I
see my colleagues operating on people in
their 40s even earlier early 50s with
anterior cruciate ligament tears who
need that ligament intact to be able to
participate in the sports that they want
to so there's been a great growth in the
athletic participation and you add to
that what's also done is it's not just
men that are doing it it's women women
are actively involved in athletics so
we've now seen kind of a blurring of the
lines between who gets what kind of
injury now now it's true men are tend to
be much more involved in contact sports
so there's certain types of injuries
there but women are more and more
involved in athletics and we found that
certain aspects of women's anatomy
predisposes them to certain injuries for
instance anterior cruciate ligament
injuries in soccer players or other
cutting type sports there's there's
differences in the female anatomy that
has led to an increased incidence of
what we call non-contact ACL tears
anterior cruciate ligament tears whereas
in men oftentimes it has to do with a
getting hit and injury of pivoting a
pivoting injury you know on a football
field or on a basketball court but this
but women it tends to be
on contact and what we understand that
the more we can hopefully develop trends
to to prevent it
the third area is the fact that that
kids are involved in so many sports but
they tend to focus on the sport
year-round now but when I was growing up
you kind of played football or soccer in
the fall played basketball in the winter
and then played baseball in the summer
or in the warmer weather in this in the
climate in both New York now if cific if
a boy or girl is good in basketball well
they're playing on you know AAU team in
the fall then the school team in the in
the winter and then going back to an au
or a travel team you know in the in the
spring and the summer so they're playing
one sport now and that takes its toll on
the specific body parts involved so for
example some of the problems with
baseball players elbow injuries tearing
the collateral ligament the ulnar
collateral ligament which is the
ligament on the inside of your elbow
here the so called Tommy John surgery
that's necessary to reconstruct that
ligament used to be you know listen
before Frank Jobe did that procedure in
Tommy John it was almost unheard of now
you start the scene these injuries and
high school players sometimes even
younger because they're playing the
sports year-round and it's taking its
toll the mechanics may not be exact
right increased stresses so that's one
thing you have to be very careful of
this the these athletic stresses that we
subject children to during their during
their growing years and the impact on
this skeleton as well as the soft
tissues
well obesity is a significant problem in
this country right I mean you see that
in the newspapers and the medical
journals it is an issue and I say that
to you now two days after my own
physician told me that I needed to lose
ten percent of my body weight so I'm
speaking from experience here but there
is no doubt that obesity carries a takes
its toll on the wear and tear on the
joints and it clearly is a risk factor
for the development of the Jenner of
arthritis but even more so all right the
let's say you develop degenerative
arthritis in the new year and a hip and
and you have significant obesity a
successful hip or knee replacement is
certainly possible but their risk
factors are greater the chance of
complications of greater when in
patients that are obese than those that
are not obese with respect to you know
cardiac pulmonary and other
complications so it has it has an impact
not only on the development of the
problem but also in the ability to
effectively treat it and have a
successful result
I think that we're an act where we are
an active population and we should be
and maybe we should be even more
attitude some of the problems with
obesity but what I found is that and and
exercise is important all right I think
people should exercise every day or at
least three four or five times a week in
some way shape or form I do think you
have to be concerned to be aware of the
impact of repetitive impact type
activities you know they're running
continually running on hard surfaces
right and it's one thing if you're a
high-level athlete training to do that
but more for the recreational athletes
the people they're just trying to
maintain their own health I think you
should do things like cross train right
you want to run one day next they use an
exercise bicycle switch to an elliptical
right in other words don't don't subject
u-joints to the same type of wear and
tear or impact activity on any one day
secondly see that's talking about the
joints but don't forget there's a large
area of soft tissues soft tissues refer
to the non bony parts that connect the
joints that are in the joints so for
Annie it's the ligaments around the
joint the anterior cruciate ligament
that I mentioned before or the menisci
ID you know the semicircular shock
absorbers in the knee you know you also
have to make make sure that in and as
part of any exercise program you have to
stretch warm up right make sure these
these soft tissues are ready for
exercise as opposed to just going at it
cold so when you when you walk through
central park all right or anywhere else
where there's a people exercise you can
see people pushing against trees all
right over there back against the fence
there stretching right and there's a lot
to be said for that and I think that it
will it can do something to prevent
injury I think that's that's critic
critically important the other aspect of
this is what do you do after exercise
right so you do have to have some effect
of you know not just stopping sudden
suddenly but you do want to you know
cool down afterwards and make sure that
you let you give you a chant by yourself
your body a chance to recover something
to be said for you know the fact that
exercise does cause some
injury and the body needs time to
recover so you need to have some periods
of rest so when I say exercise every day
if you exercise different muscle groups
to different to different things you
give certain parts of your body a chance
to recover as you exercise other parts
your body I think a third suggestion
that I think is important I think that
all these aerobic exercises should be
combined with some anaerobic or strength
type exercises you know weight lifting
things like that to really maintain not
only muscle tone but maybe increase
muscle size a little bit i'm not talking
about extreme bodybuilding i'm talking
about doing things to maintain that that
part of your of your muscle health as
well i think that's important you know
and i'm a believer also personally in
using some anti-inflammatories and
associated with the exercise as I've
gotten older alright I've used
over-the-counter anti-inflammatories
because I think it has a a an
anti-inflammatory effect and decreases
some of the aches and pains you may
develop as part of your exercise program
i think that's that's very important
women bring a certain different set of
issues that have to be considered and
from women I guess the big issue is
osteoporosis osteopenia and now and we
know that women as they go through
menopause and their hormonal balance
changes they tend to develop some
weakening of their bone osteoporosis
osteoporosis is the condition that means
that you're losing bone mass osteopenia
is a description of a lesser condition
which you're progressing to osteoporosis
and what that means is that because of
various factors in activity can be one
your genetic makeup as well as the
hormonal issues that I just referred to
you you're decreasing bone mass that
that predisposes to risk of injury easy
for easy fracture for relatively minor
type falls so there's a big emphasis on
maintaining bone health particularly in
women now I see osteoporosis and
osteopenia occurs in men also but to a
lesser extent now the interesting part
here is that that if if if obesity has
any positive effect the right and I'm
not suggesting obesity for anybody but
obese men and women right older men and
women tend not to have problems with
with osteoporosis the reason is because
their body weight subjects their
skeleton to sufficient weight that you
know the bones respond to physiologic
stress so if I just lie in bed and I
don't have a weight-bearing force am I
on my bones well the processes that
resorb bone that take away bone outstrip
the processes that deposit bone when
you're up on it and when you're up and
active in things the processes that
deposit bone because of the stress you
know exceed those that that resorb bone
or take away bone but if you're not
doing anything in activity so you're
going to predispose to more osteoporosis
so being active is important and if you
have a lot of weight on it all right
that tends to be positive but that's not
the message here the message is activity
and evaluation of osteoporosis as a
problem
most women think that that this is a
problem that develops after menopause
but the real time to treat this is going
as at the age when you think you may
enter menopause so I'm looking at it
then evaluating it and beginning
treatment at a time that so you prevent
yourself from even getting osteopenia as
opposed to finally out afterwards then
have to kind of try and move your way
back into a more acceptable range so I
bone health is a very important thing
for women
9 and we're now probably six months into
the health care reform debate and the
next two months will be critical in
determining what healthcare will look
like in the future as president the
American Academy of Orthopaedic Surgeons
we have been actively involved in the
health care debate because we represent
our members 18,000 orthopedic surgeons
practicing in this country there are
some basic tenants some basic principles
of health care reform that we think are
important the first is patients
shouldn't be able to access the
physicians that they want to see and for
us it means specialties specialists as
an orthopedic surgeons we we believe and
we know that we're the experts in
orthopedic and musculoskeletal problems
and we think in this country patience
you'll be able to see specialists who
can provide the care that they need so a
system that that allows them to do that
it would be is a good one a system that
makes it difficult to do that or
decreases access to specialists would be
one that we couldn't support because
you're taking a step backwards from the
development of medical care in this
country which has developed to such a
great extent and really is that some of
the is as some of the highest levels in
the world and I do believe that the
medical care provider in this country is
the most up-to-date innovative found
anywhere and that's important
issue of of coverage of those Americans
that are uninsured and we also think
that's important the uninsured in this
country should have insurance right but
it has to be in a system that can
support it so it should be affordable
with appropriate access one of our
concerns is that the system as it's
currently constructed in this country
that doesn't make it easy to add 20 30
or 40 million new patients to the system
Medicare is a good example of it
Medicare when it was introduced in 1965
was a new program there was a lot of
resistance to it but it's proven to be a
very important health care insurance
program for the seniors patients people
over the age of 60 or 65 depending upon
eligibility that's very important the
one of the issues is that each year we
hear that Medicare is getting closer and
closer to being insolvent bankruptcy
right because there are so many people
who have Medicare now and there's only a
little bit number of funds available and
Congress has not been able to enact a
long-term solution to the Medicare
problem now if you end as I said 20 30
or 40 million more people to the for
health care coverage in this country
you're you're stressing a system that's
already been excessively stressed and I
know that current legislation
legislation in the house and the Senate
has ways that they've you know they're
going to pay for this and such right but
my concern is that on paper it looks
good five years from now it may not work
out exactly as they envisioned just like
Medicare didn't work out exactly as they
envisioned way back when when they first
started it so I think that that's also a
concern
another area that we think is
particularly important is in the area of
liability reform you know doing
something about the explosion of
liability cases malpractice cases in
this country frivolous cases it's gotten
to the point where any physician not
just orthopedic surgeons about any
physician practices medicine in a
defensive way so-called defensive
medicine do I really need to get that
cat scan do I really need to get an
x-ray on this patient well probably not
but you know there's a small chance it
could be there and if I miss something
you know it could be a suit against this
or and such so that's what we've come to
and so much of that adds to the cost of
healthcare and it's very disconcerting
and disheartening to us our organization
that in the two main pieces of
legislation in the house and now one
that's going to be introduced into the
Senate that there is no meaningful
liability reform and and which is
astounding to me because the
Congressional Budget Office a
nonpartisan group said that at the very
least over ten years you would take away
fifty four billion dollars from the
course to health care in this country
with some very limited liability reform
issues so that's that's another very
important one that I think right now
we're just missing in this
different types of
Bridge for different parts of the
population we are one in this country
where most of it is employer-based
coverage and and all employer-based
insurance that is provided is different
you know the level of coverage is
different the deductibles are different
the out-of-pocket insurance is different
so you know I guess if you've seen one
health health insurance plan then you've
seen one health insurance plan because
they're they're not the same then you
have Medicare which ensures i think last
count 50 or 60 million people in this
country that's a very big program that's
a government program that also has
undergone some changes but it does not
have the oversight or the or the
monitoring that you see in the private
insurances the HMOs the managed care
companies Medicaid as you know is a is
the insurance that's provided for
indigent patients people that are a
certain level below the poverty line
that's federally supported the state
supported that's a different level of
coverage so you've got this amalgamation
of different level of different types of
coverage that together insurers you know
oh 180 or 200 and/or million people in
this country then there's the uninsured
wish again have another another no
insurance but tentacles go to the
emergency room or pay out of pocket for
these things so even in countries that
have had national health insurance
government induced across the board what
develops in those countries is a private
insurance system that allows people to
augment their coverage you know have
access to different dot is better
coverage maybe different hospitals all
those things and we don't have that here
because you don't have one consistent
system that's why it's so hard to reform
health care because you're not reforming
one thing you're reforming a system that
has in multiple different parts very
challenging
healthcare being a physician can be a
small business right and that's what it
is for the vast majority of physicians
in this country you have an office you
have expenses you have to generate
revenue to pay your expenses and that's
different than a Kaiser Permanente or a
large healthcare system like the mayo
clinic or others that others like that
that are all encompassing so it's and
when you can when you if you consider an
episode of health care from the time a
patient enters that you know it's nice
to go to see their physician until their
or comes to the emergency room until
there they are now cured or is no longer
a problem they will see multiple
practitioners along the way physicians
non-physicians physician extenders
therapists pharmacists you know a whole
variety of health healthcare providers
in most systems in the country those
will be each one of those people those
providers could be part of a different
system so there's the lack of
coordination a place like Kaiser manages
the entire all the episodes of care the
entire episode of care and all the
different pieces to it you can certainly
do that more more effectively and more
efficiently the question is can you
extrapolate that or build that and to
dip into all different communities in
this country and that's hard to do
because it's not set up that way
physicians physicians have organized
themselves to a certain extent but they
haven't organized themselves as much as
we should so if you look at in this
current health care debate if the
government considers the American
Medical Association as they spokes group
for American medicine right well what
does that mean I'm not a member of the
AMA I think only seventeen percent of
physicians in this country are members
of the American Medical Association so
do they represent the physicians in this
country probably not right that's why
there's been such pushback and sometimes
you know significant you and cry about
some of the positions the AMA has taken
every every 30 years ago when the AMA
was the medical organization this
country it was more reasonable expected
anticipated that they could be the
spokes group for American medicine but
now it's changed there are large and
large physician organizations the
American College of Surgeons when I
think 60,000 members our organization
with almost 20,000 members that not only
do we have large numbers of physicians
represented based upon this specialty
involved but in addition every group has
a legislative office our our
organization we have 14 in full-time
people working our legislative affairs
office right that we are actively
involved in the in the in the
legislative process you know pushing the
pushing for the certain the principles a
practice and reform that we think are
important if so many groups have that
because they're large enough and they
have the resources to do it now watch
now what you really effectively need is
coalition's of groups to work together
so one of the one of the groups that
were involved in with the American
College of Surgeons is a group a
coalition of surgical society of
representing surgeons and other
specialists specialists trying to pursue
a common agenda in this health care
reform debate so the fact is it's very
hard to have to organize physicians
because the physician groups are now so
well represented by within their own
specialty and
have lobbyists or or legislative affairs
offices in Washington DC that they can
go it alone so to speak so is there it
is there a need for organization
probably because it can speak with a lot
of voice but we've learned that what
worked 30 years ago when there was one
organization like the AMA is not the
case anymore because other organizations
want to speak up right and and be heard
because they're their opinions or their
needs and priorities at different than
other organizations
so I'll speak personally now it would
always bother me in the last few years
as practicing medicine has become more
you know bureaucratic more difficult
more red tape more paperwork and such
and and and and maybe not as financially
rewarding as it used to be in the past
because things have changed when I here
at colleagues say I would never tell my
son at door to go to medical school now
alright it's just too hard it's just not
what it used to be all right well you
know I don't want to seem you know to
pollyannaish here but I think being a
physician is it is one of the greatest
things you can do and so I have a son
who is a a second-year medical student
at the Vanderbilt the university school
of medicine and when he when he told me
he thought about going to medical school
I thought it was the greatest thing in
the world all right I encourage them to
do it you could do whatever he wanted to
but what I ever discourage him from
being a physician no I never would
because you know all these other things
notwithstanding everything we hear about
from the time you walk into the
examining room to talk to a patient so
the time you leave that is a opportunity
to be valued and cherished right because
the relationship you develop with a
patient is very powerful it's very
meaningful and the people who should be
physicians should recognize the power of
that relationship and that interaction
and if you do that then you would never
even think about about discouraging
somebody from doing it from being a
physician
the the trend
concern me and orthopedics probably
those that apply to medicine is in
general this because of the changing
nature of healthcare you have to see so
many patients more patients than before
in order to you know basically balance
the books and your practices and things
that it takes away from each among those
interactions each one of those
individual interactions and I think
there's something that's lost their
there's a tendency for surgeons to be
seen only as procedure asst well you
know operate take care of them then
we're finished right yeah it's great to
be able to operate and improve
somebody's quality of life like we do
but you know it's the interactions that
I think are important and when when
somebody listen I'll see you 30 35
patients in a day and it's a long day
but when somebody tells me they see 60
70 or 80 patients in a day right I say
boy I mean that's that's difficult to do
in a meaningful way so that concerns me
when I hear
I think that a lot of it is talent but
character is a very important thing let
me tell you about about professionalism
and in medicine we can we can teach
individuals when we have a one of the
largest residency programs in the
country 12 residency is 62 orthopedic
surgery residence in a five-year program
almost without exception we can train
them to know what they need to know to
be an orthopedic surgeon learn how to
operate on the important procedures and
orthopedic surgeons but and we can even
teach them a little bit how to interact
with patients however you can't teach
them to have the ethics right and the
professional and that's necessary to be
a physician they need to come to us with
the ethics that their parents have to do
that and we layer onto that the
professionalism of being an orthopedic
surgeon if you can be as talented as you
as you as anybody but if you're not if
you don't have the professionalism the
interactions with patients the ability
to to understand you know what you're
doing it happen and how to care for
patient how to interact with patients
right then you've not fulfilled the
responsibilities you have of being a
physician
my advice is that you should always
recognize what it is that attracted you
to being a physician and what a trap
which I think should have attracted you
to being a physician surgeon or a
internist or any other medical specialty
what should have attracted you is the
ability to make patients better to
interact with patients and to take
somebody who is who is ill and make them
better somebody that can't do what they
need to do and help them do what they
need to do that's a very powerful thing
and you and the next generation of
physicians should ever see the power in
that and the attraction of it because
when all is said and done that's a very
satisfying part of being a physician and
with all the difficulties we have with
you know the bureaucracy and managing
practices and health care reform that's
a constant in this the relationship you
have with you with your patients and I
think that goes a long way to making for
a very satisfied physician for many
years
well as I mentioned before my father was
an accountant and he told me don't
become an accountant because I have to
work too hard so but I don't remember
him working like I work but then again
I'm glad he told me not to become an
accountant because I couldn't have
family the real heroes in life are to me
other people that have have problems
have medical problems have personal
problems that have to persevere against
significant odds right when I get up I
get up early in the morning go to work
I'm happy to go to work right I don't
have to die not had to deal with those
things but I see a lot of my patients I
seen a lot of people in the hospital you
know patients in the hospital it is very
challenging for them to do that the
people that can can persevere in in a
situation where that makes life
difficult even tragic or right those are
my heroes
I think I would have dinner with Babe
Ruth and Lou Gehrig right just the three
of us I've read their biographies
multiple biographies on both some reason
I I find that that time of that era very
interesting and I think it would be it
would it would be very interesting to to
have to be able to talk to to the
greatest legends right in in baseball
now on the other hand it may not be the
most stimulating conversations
keeps me up at night is thinking about
what I'm going to do the next day I
operate on Tuesdays and Wednesdays so
monday night and tuesday night the day
before the surgery is the next day those
are the times that i probably stay up
longer in bed knots you know but trying
to get to sleep thinking about the case
into the next day what i'm going to do
making sure I've got all the bases
covered making sure I'm completely
prepared
you know I think that there's an
expression i think my father used to use
this one one one swallow does not a
summer make or a spring or something
like that you know i guess there's maybe
a million physicians in this country all
right i got any other group right that
we may not not everyone may may function
in the same way or it may be a you know
a shining star they're probably some
exceptions to that like there isn't any
other profession but you don't want to
judge the whole profession by that right
and because i think for the most part
the vast majority you know ninety
percent ninety-five percent plus the
physicians in this country are out there
taking care of patients trying to make
lives lives better right there's
something there probably some exceptions
out there you know absolutely right like
any other profession but this is this is
a healing profession this is where you
take care of people and try and make
them better as i said that is a very
powerful thing and if the physicians if
you maximize that opportunity as i said
from the time you walk in the door from
to the time you leave from a time you
show up in the emergency room to see a
patient until you you finish taking care
of them that's the opportunity that's
the opportunity to make patients to have
patience recognize the value of what
physicians do the importance of what we
do and to cement that patient-physician
relationship which is so important which
is really is the foundation I think the
foundation of medical care not only here
but anyway